okay if I tell you about Donald Trump's
constant confused speech but don't tell
you when it's happening to Democrats I
would be a hypocrite I respect you too
much to play that game so I must tell
you today I must that Joe Biden's
speeches are increasingly confused and
odd yesterday during a campaign speech
in South Carolina which will vote on
Saturday Joe Biden claimed to be a
candidate for the United States Senate
rather than the presidency and he also
referred to voting for the other Biden
if you don't like what you see which
maybe was a joke or not I mean I
genuinely can't tell when I look at this
clip I'm worried about Joe Biden just
like I'm worried about Donald Trump I'm
not playing political games with this
when I see something I say something so
let's look at the clips which are truly
odd this is from South Carolina
yesterday you're the ones that sent
Barack Obama the presidency and I have a
simple proposition here I'm here to ask
you for your help where I come from you
don't get far unless you ask my name is
Joe Biden I'm a Democratic candidate for
the United States Senate look me over if
you're like we see help out if not both
the other by give me a look though okay
that's all I've really got to say to you
I'm a Bob this is so strange that it's
actually hard to understand exactly what
Joe Biden is saying here but he says I'm
Joe Biden running for US Senate if you
like what you see help out if not vote
for the other Biden that's what I'm
hearing let's look at it one more time
you're the ones that sent Barack Obama
the presidency and I have a simple
proposition here I'm here to ask you for
your help where I come from you don't
get far unless you ask my name is Joe
Biden I'm a Democratic candidate for the
United States Senate look me over if
you're like we see helped out if not
both the other by give me a look though
okay that's all I really got to say to
you I'm a bob I just don't know I mean
what do you what do you make of this I
get lots of emails when this stuff
happens saying this is just sad and Joe
Biden
have run I get some emails from people
who say this is clearly stress-related
not cognitive decline I don't know how
you could really know one way or the
other at this point just from these
videos a couple of people wrote to me
about this and said David this is Joe
Biden's stutter now I don't know about
that stuttering is nothing to make fun
of
I know stutterers and I don't know that
stuttering would cause someone who's
running for president to say I'm running
for Senate I just don't think that that
has anything to do with a stutter I'm
glad to be corrected if I'm wrong Joe
Biden has had a stutter his entire life
if you look at videos of him from 2012
when he was running circles around Paul
Ryan when debating him the VP debate you
see a night and day difference if you
look even earlier in Joe Biden's career
the difference is even more pronounced
so none of this stuff is funny to me
when Trump does it when it happens to
Biden it's concerning cognitive decline
if that's what's going on is not a joke
it's not funny it's a medical condition
and just as importantly if we are
selecting someone to be President which
we are
whether it's Trump or Biden or Bernie or
whoever we want to be sure that the
candidate has their full faculties
available to them the job is extremely
demanding it's physically demanding it's
emotionally stressful every single day I
mean okay I guess if your Trump and you
just tweet and watch Fox News maybe it's
not every day
distant decisions are riding on what you
do Trump opting out out of that on a lot
of days but in principle every single
day a lot is riding on the cognitive
abilities of the President of the United
States so I don't know what's going on
it's weird we have more and more clips
of this just like we have more and more
clips of Donald Trump behaving oddly and
I want to hear from you what what you
think while we're talking about South
Carolina I will mention tonight there's
a debate in South Carolina we'll be
covering it live on Saturday is the
South Carolina primary and let's take a
look at the polls Joe Biden is still
leading in South Carolina in an average
of recent polls leading every individual
poll except from 111 days ago where
Bernie had tied Joe Biden in South
Carolina we
been talking about South Carolina sort
of as the place where Tom Styer could
grab some delegates and he's right on
the brink of that 15% viability
threshold Tom Steyer polling 14.7
average in recent polls as high as 20 as
low as 7 and no matter what happens
Saturday in South Carolina I do expect
everybody who's in right now to stay
through Super Tuesday I don't know when
you have three days really two full days
between the Saturday South Carolina
primary and Tuesday's Super Tuesday
primaries in many many states I don't
know of any reason to get out after
Saturday before seeing what happens on
Tuesday but I would not be totally
shocked if you see some exits after
Tuesday depending on the results Tom
Styer if he ends up with no delegates in
South Carolina nor in any other state I
assume steyr will be out by midnight on
Tuesday night tulsi I mean listen tulsi
should have been out a while ago she
doesn't have a path to a single delegate
maybe if again she ends up with 0
delegates after Super Tuesday maybe
tulsi will get out Amy Klobuchar if she
does really poorly on Tuesday maybe she
would look at getting out although she
was putting a lot of energy into
California and maybe it's conceivable
she could pull something out there so
join me tonight for the last debate
before the South Carolina primary and is
it actually it might be the last debate
before Super Tuesday unless they're
squeezing in one more on on Sunday or
Monday we will be live at 7:15 p.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube Twitter and
Facebook then twitch alone for the
entire debate join me tonight and make
sure you're following the show on
Instagram for more coverage of the 20/20
primary at David Pakman show on
Instagram while you're there follow me
at David Pakman on Instagram as well one
of our sponsors is privacy calm they're
giving you $5 when you sign up for their
completely free service at privacy calm
slash Pakman I've been using privacy for
a little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set up anytime you
buy something
online or on the phone instead of
actually using your real credit card
number the privacy app and the browser
plugin let you give each company a
randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click and the payment is taken out of
your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cashback and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a $25 a
month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get $5 to spend when you
sign up at privacy calm / Pakman